[Music]
sovereignty answers the question who
rules and however that question is
answered tells you something very
central about any country it is a
fundamental question in political
science we like to say who rules and why
Lincoln says every nation has a central
idea from which all its minor thoughts
radiate that idea would be expressed in
the notion of sovereignty who really
does get to decide who's in charge in
the American Revolution it might have
been the greatest warrior George
Washington fact it was he but is that
how he was chosen or why he was chosen
it might have been the best more boring
person the oldest family and the eldest
son of the oldest family and all of the
British Empire and that would have been
George the third but they chucked him
out it might have been the richest guy
one of those with John Hancock so those
are competing claims that are famous in
history which one did they choose how
did they decide where does sovereignty
lie in a country with these principles
so in the 63rd Federalists one of our
readings what does Madison say is unique
about the American government this is
complicated because it's one of the most
complicated sentences the man ever wrote
somebody read it the true distinction
between these and the American
government's lie in the total exclusion
of the people and their collective
capacity from any share in the ladder
and not in the total exclusion of the
representatives of the people from the
administration of the former so the
meaning of that sentence depends
entirely on what ladder and what former
means and it's a heck of a deal to
figure that out and I'm just going to
assert to you that I know what it means
and you guys can prove me wrong next
time but just remember that what is
playing in the sentence without trying
to identify whatever he's talking about
former and ladder is that the people in
their collective capacity have been
entirely excluded from something right
what is that something in America in the
government of the United States and the
federal government what is it that the
people do absolutely none of make the
laws create a judiciary branch they're
not judges they're not legislatures and
they are not executives over the law
they are entirely excluded from the
operation of the government in that odd
right in England and Great Britain
at the time of the American Revolution
who was the executive that came to us
and his ministers right and who was the
sovereign right so the one possessing
legitimate title to rule occupied the
executive branch in Athens who was the
legislature the people the people and
who was the sovereign the people you
know why anthems didn't last a long time
I professor Paul Ray in the history
department isn't you know very brilliant
man it's got these three books on Sparta
that's just an awesome achievement
Sparta lasted a long time and he is the
one who pointed this out to me I had not
known it Sparta had division of powers
in the Constitution where the anthems
just the people would meet and they were
always changing their mind and so in
America it is different because unlike
Athens
unlike England unlike even Sparta all
the sovereignty is ours we may not be
governed except by our consent and we
don't give it no governing all
government is illegitimate except with
that and of course it follows from that
that in the practical operation of the
government since unanimity is impossible
majority rule and of course in a college
in a proper College if you disagree
somebody's wrong we're here to find out
who's wrong and who's right
well we always disagree how we ever
gonna figure it out right but yeah so
there's gonna be voting and there's
gonna be disagreement and we're not
gonna reach unanimity why is the
majority the right thing seems like it's
more probable that more people since
it's not a mob at that time because
they're voting on something in a
Republican fashion that they would have
considered it in a way that would refine
their opinions ooh that's really novel I
don't think it's true all men are
created equal you got 300 people 160
want to do a and 140 you want to do not
a if you do what the hundred and forty
says you've got yourself an aristocracy
right in other words the majority of
equals souls has to stand in for the
unanimous consent right and in anything
not fundamental or anything that
involves the ongoing operation of the
government that's what you need see so
the point is you're gonna have
majorities rule you're gonna have
representation and that gives rise to
something new and Madison says that it's
never happened before its unique the
sovereign is the people as expressed by
what I'll introduce a new phrase that
Abraham Lincoln's liked the people as
they express their wealth through their
constitutional majority is the only true
sovereign of a free people and so that's
where sovereignty is that's where the
right to say the legitimate title to
rule is but those people the sovereign
are entirely excluded from the operation
of the government do you see now how the
first check on the government is that we
must consent
but the second check on the government
is that we who have the power to consent
do not run the government and that
second check is a check on us in the
argument between the Federalists and the
anti-federalists the anti-federalists
argue a lot that that local is more
trustworthy and they got their say
extensively right because for most of
American history but not lately local
government did most everything the
federal government is the most powerful
of our governments but it's a government
of enumerated powers right and so
limited in what it can do supreme and
what it can do limited in what it can do
right but the Federalists counter is not
central is better and it's certainly
true that the constitutional government
was called the Constitutional Convention
was called to make a more powerful
government at the center the Federalist
answer is that every human exercise of
power must be restrained by reason and
there are constitutional forms that have
to be implemented that can help bring
that out and if the first constitutional
form is representation the method by
which we give our ongoing consent the
second is the separation between
sovereignty and power and Madison even
says this just think it's it'll be great
to have a big republic he says because
of whispering campaign won't be very
effective don't you notice in your
relations with other people that it's a
great thing if you can say out loud what
you really mean and that all friendships
depend on that and all goodwill and all
sustenance of good relations means
people need to be able to talk candidly
and Madison says because it's going to
be big it's
gonna have to be more candid but also
add the fact that these constituencies
that we have are spread all over the
place right Congress our little compact
constituencies equal in population
roughly but all over the country but
then the Senate is these big states and
then the president comes to be through a
third way that's changed some over time
but forever now the Electoral College
barring some relation to the popular
vote but also direct relation to
carrying a sufficient number of states
which means the president won't spread
across the country right and so that
means that we gotta wait for elections
and to influence in elections we've got
to talk to a lot of people across a vast
area and Madison says that'll make us
candid
hard to lie you know I mean it sounds
kind of funny to say that it's hard to
lie in American politics because we all
think politicians are all liars right
but are they is this like the Soviet
Union contest what they say and they'll
shoot you they write the newspapers
right this is a fierce battle for public
opinion out in the open in America all
the time and it has to go on for a long
time before we actually reach a decision
was it Christian who said you know it
takes forever as Steve maybe who said
you know elections take forever you know
and you got to have a big build-up and
it makes us fight Madison thinks that's
good
I thinks it's good good it takes time
and and we can't do anything ourselves
and we can't even change all the
government it wants it takes at least
six years to change everything in the
government and that remarkable so you
get
consent and that gives rise to
representation and that gives rise to a
separation between the sovereign and the
government and Madison says this has
never been done before
you
[Music]